joining me via Skype this week is ayaan
Hirsi Ali I hope that most of you
already know I on but in case you don't
her story is truly an incredible one
that takes her from a childhood in
Somalia to an elected member of
parliament in Holland to a fearless free
speech advocate hated by both the
extreme right and the regressive left
we'll dive deeper into her life's
incredible journey shortly but before we
do that I wanted to take a moment to
talk about why people like I on actually
matter as our show has gained momentum
here I realized that what we're doing is
really becoming an influential force for
the things that I believe that mattered
namely the battle of ideas free speech
and liberal values at the end of the day
though I want this to be about more than
talk because the repercussions of these
ideas that we're talking about aren't
just abstract notions there's stark
realities for so many people ayaan Hirsi
Ali is a survivor in every sense of the
word she survived genital mutilation as
a child she survived a forced marriage
to a cousin she survived the
cold-blooded murder of a friend in broad
daylight in Amsterdam and subsequent
death threats many people would have
given up after any of these horrific
events many people would have just
accepted that this is what life has
given them and remained quiet many
people right this very second are doing
just that by the way I find no fault
with these people who remain silent
under such subjugation they see no way
out and sadly even those in the secular
world who want to help them fear the
repercussions if they speak out not I on
those she is brave Liam boldly fought
for women's rights brought the issue of
female genital mutilation out in the
open and relentlessly made her life
story a Cause bigger than herself it's
easy to sit back and privately talk
about these things or tweet about them
from the comfort of your own home but
she's actually out there putting her
life on the line after they already
tried to take it from her I want to be
very clear here that when I talk about
these issues i'm talking about ideas and
not people this seems to be a major
sticking point in this conversation and
I really hope that we can eventually get
past that not just for the health of the
debate but for all the young people
currently being indoctrinated with this
ideology imagine if a political party
had a platform that included female
genital mutilation
inforce marriage and death for apostates
absolutely insane and ridiculous right
well guess what religious ideas cultural
ideas any ideas deserve the exact same
scrutiny no matter how uncomfortable it
makes us I for one would rather live in
a society that deals with uncomfortable
truths out in the open than one that
leaves huge portions of people alone in
the dark
you